do our best to get through it so if we
have any technical glitches i'll
apologize in advance but
certainly reach out to us if you do i've
got a short script that i need to read
to open the meeting
as chair of the environment agricultural
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the government 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant
to executive order 2020-04
this public party is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may fall
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this notice complies with
house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting she'll call
271-3600
or email hcs
leg.state dot new hampshire
dot u s in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
christina is dyer is the staff that is
assisting us today
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote i'm going to hold off
calling the role until after the
commissioner's
presentation before we start the first
hearing
so at this point in time me
representative pearl uh due to 91a
we need to each member to state where
they are and
uh their names before we start the
hearing my apologies
i have to do that before i do the
commissioner yes please
our clerk is not yet in attendance to
call the role
i don't believe
oh she's coming in the door now so you
can pause for one minute let the door be
seated
so
all right when the clerk is ready we're
going to start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
i'll turn it over to the floor when
she's ready
okay representative aaron
here in the community
representative contour here represented
verbal
representative verbal is here but he's
working on getting audio in he'll be in
in just a minute
representative arnold here
here in the committee room
representative
in over the line
representative mason
mason
present no one's in the room
i represent sanborn uh present
alone
very hard to hear you
gail sanborn present and alone
uh i am at home in my uh study alone
there are other people in the house i'm
in dover new hampshire
representative
good morning i am in my home in my
sewing room and i'm alone representative
i'm here in the committee room thank you
i'm um alone in my home office a cat or
two may walk by
murray uh present and i am here alone in
my room but there are other
people in my house i'm here in amherst
representative
here at my home in keene uh my
daughter's downstairs but i'm alone in
the room
representative kaplan yes i'm here in
henniker in my home there's a
couple other people with me in the house
but i'm here in the study alone
can't hear you representative hyland
yes rept highland here i'm alone in my
home office in francestown new hampshire
i just have the dog with me
representative perez i'm here
um alone in my house in milford uh with
my dog and my pet rabbit and mr chair
i am here in the committee room
anyone that we missed on the role this
is representative
this is representative virgo can you
hear okay me
but this time i'm going to welcome the
commissioner of agriculture commissioner
sean jasper we
appreciate you coming in today i want to
give you a little time to introduce
yourself
to the new committee members and discuss
what the department does and how the
committee works with people
thank you chairman my pleasure to be
here i appreciate
the opportunity to be here in person and
i hope that everyone on
on the zoom call can hear me as well
i'll
try to keep my volume up to catch the
mic
so i have been uh commissioner of the
department of agriculture markets and
food for just over
three years now and um
obviously this is our primary policy
committee
that we work with in the house for the
past
i think we've had a very good working
relationship
with the committee we very much
appreciate that
for the returning members this will be a
bit of a refresher and for the new
members
hopefully give you a little better idea
of what the department does because
certainly
when i became commissioner even i didn't
even realize
just what a wide reach the department
has so i want to spend a few minutes
just going over and
mr chairman at your discretion it might
be easier to
answer questions as we go along if that
works for you
dr crawford is also on the zoom call
and he's available hopefully for more
questions as we
go through the presentation because some
of the more technical things with
particularly with animal
industry he would be better suited to to
answer
so the general function of the
department is to promote
regulate agriculture and all its
branches and we
attempt to gather and disseminate
information on agriculture
crop production market activity and
other subjects consistent with the
responsibilities of the department
we cooperate with other agencies in the
state and federal governments
the university of new hampshire
commodity and consumer groups
in the public interest in all who are
engaged within the state of any form of
agriculture or its allies
locations or advice on those activities
and of course we do
whatever else the legislature tasks us
with
so to give you an idea of the scope of
animal industry
and these are estimates because there is
no exact count
for any number of animals but we have a
fairly good idea
there are about three thousand and four
three hundred and four thousand dogs in
the state of new hampshire
332 000 cats
37 000 pet birds 21 000 horses
1.67 million poultry
in 34 000 flocks most of those are
small backyard blocks are only a few
large commercial operations 33 000
cattle just about 7 000 pigs
just under 5 000 goats 1500
deer elk in bison and about 2 500
llamas in our pockets so a lot of
animals to keep track of
who our constituents of course the 1.3
million people in the state in about 521
households there are about 4 100
farms reported in the census 2017 which
is down
from just under 4 400 in 2012.
the animal industry division supports
and promotes agriculture and serves
consumers and business for the benefit
of public health which
primarily we do consider ourselves to be
about
public protection in many different ways
so what health is
is one of the most important things that
the animal industry
really is does what they do to try to
protect
a healthy environment in the economy
and that control or attempt to prevent
and control contagious and infectious
diseases of livestock and poultry
for the benefit of the public health in
the economy
why do we regulate animal health in
zoonotic diseases we're very concerned
about that that's
you know if we know or believe that
there's a good possibility
that the current pandemic organ came
through zoonotic diseases so that's a
very important
of ours food safety particularly now
through the
fisma which there's a bill on that later
in the day
regulatory costs the environment
environmental implications of
agriculture
disposal of animal waste
and carcasses and all of those type of
things
so health risks there are 1400 pathogens
known to affect humans
and 60 percent of those are dramatic
so it is very important to
regulate those areas
core mission of animal industry is to
control and eradicate
contagious and infectious diseases of
domestic animals in
poultry or rsa 436.
the indus the division also
has emergency preparedness
responsibilities and response
state lead for emergency support
function for agriculture cultural
natural resources and that does take up
a fair amount of time
dr crawford's time he is the lead person
for the department and that
we are prepared to deal with the
situation
we have surveillance program for
eradication
monitors swine garbage feeders livestock
dealers poultry dealers
intra-state movement of poultry small
testing
quotation requirements official id on
sheep of ghosts
diseases of course we work
with the new hampshire veterinary
diagnostic lab which i
share the budgetary oversight
responsible
with the lab
other activities as the statutes direct
their license and inspection of
pet vending businesses assist law
enforcement with investigations of
animal welfare and abuse complaints
one of the things i want to know here is
a lot of people think that we have
that primary responsibility we are not a
law enforcement
agency when it comes to animal abuse
reports have to be made to your local
law enforcement of the state police
we assist them when we request in
determining
actually the condition of the health of
the animal
conditions but people who often call us
thinking that we have the primary
response
for that or do not we run the state
uh spay and neuter program which is very
important i'll get into some
statistics on that a little later dr
crawford is a
ex-official member of the board of
veterinary medicine and
thankfully that the oversight of
that board has been moved over into
licenses office of professional
licensure which
is a big relief to me
terms of people thinking that i actually
had
some oversight over actually never did
so of course on the administrative side
um budget rulemaking
they have administrative hearing
processes
personnel management
there's a prescription drug monitoring
program advisory council with martin
crocker is part of
part of the governor's commission on
animal cruelty
and those are just a few of the things
greatest challenges we face as a
department particularly
i think in animal industry is the
resources do not match
the jobless when i took over this job
from
commissioner merrill she referred to us
as being in
triage we are a little better
now having most of our positions built
but we are still in triage mode in some
areas
so we are constantly
having to determine what is the most
important
i think one of the most important on our
list that we need
substantial non-agriculture and time
resources
really are the pet vending expectations
as i think we all know
that the law was changed and reduced the
number of
pets required for licensing
when it comes to health certificates
from 50 to
25 which is put a big strain on
on the department we only receive one
additional person so we are really in
failure mode and i told
the legislature and the governor at that
time that
we would be in failure mode this program
would eliminate a number of resources
we're doing the best that we
talk about database in a while
he will actually help us deal with that
i know i've got to speed up a little bit
although i don't
stand a little late i don't know if i
get my full half hour or not
but uh you know where we're
falling short besides uh pet been
growth with a number of small scale
stakeholders
pigs most people in many cases have
little or no husbandry or disease at all
so that we have to do a lot of education
in that area
unfortunately sometimes we don't even
know about until they're disabled
and so to decide what we do based on the
list of
things known we can't do them all we
have to
ask is it a core mission of the
department is it a food safety issue
does it involve a zoonotic disease does
it
evolve a threat to the state's economy
and prioritize based on three tiers
needs attention today
needs attention this week needs
attention when we get to it
[Music]
so i am going to try to go on
the animal population control program
which is the
spay and neuter is rsa 437a and the
purpose of this program should be to
reduce the population
of unwanted and straight dogs and cats
by encouraging the owners of dogs and
cats to have them permanently sexually
sterilized
thereby reducing potential threats to
the public health and safety
from the mid-atlantic rabies and other
sources
i think we're doing fairly well with
that um
there are about 3 000 surgeries a year
process 5 000 applications a year 60
veterinary clinics participate
monthly invoicing which i go through
every month that
sign after dr crawford has gone through
to make sure that the
appropriate amount is being charged and
we feel about four to five thousand
phone calls
a year there's one person in that
program
uh and obviously that's a lot of work
and
she's out on vacation sick day is the
work piles up is going to be very
difficult to catch up within animal
industry there are two veterinarians
force
field staff and one office staff
so in addition to that is the person in
that
population so that's a lot of work for
very few people
to do one of the looming
risks and we just really became became
aware of it
this last week is all the bersolosis
and tv testing has to be entered into
the federal database
the person who was doing that on the
federal level the feds were actually
taking our information and entering it
thankfully usda was doing it she died
that person
is not being replaced it is now our
responsibility to do that
and that is going to really complicate
things for us because the risk of not
doing that
is not being able to import or export um
cattle and other livestock to and from
the state and so that's really
not an option to not do it but it's
going to take away from
from other things the division of
agricultural development
really is our marketing and they they
try to
promote agriculture and
there's really just there we have within
the division technically our
receptionist
is uh part of that she feels an awful
lot of she feels all the questions for
everybody
and then we have one person devoted to
marco bullard
and the director herself
so not a very big division and not
enough people we have a
part we tried to get a full-time
position to assist there
we got a part-time person and then
before we were able to build it we were
given a uh
order to not until vacant position so
still not where we were like to be
the weekly market bulleted is our
official
publication of record and we have 3 500
subscribers both on email and hard
copies
the division director manages the new
hampshire building at the
eastern states exposition
by statute the building is actually
under the direct management control of
the commissioner of agriculture
somewhat unique that's not the case with
all the other buildings at eastern state
state buildings and so that is our our
sole responsibility
and of course eastern states when it is
open
to the public draws about 0.5 million a
year
a lot of them go through through the new
hampshire building
the division also partners with the new
hampshire division of forest
lands and unh cooperative extension to
run the new hampshire farm
forest in foreign garden expo which of
course last year was
um was virtual this year would be
virtual again because that
would normally be coming up right about
now
we hope to be back live next year
the division has partnered with many
other organizations
in agencies who work on promoting and
um division director is a liaison with
over
over 30 different agricultural
organizations
and assists actually in the
establishment of many of those
and the director is also our department
public information officer we published
many uh
different publications that are now
electronic and hard copy they go out to
the rest areas on
agricultural events within the state of
new hampshire where they are what
they're going on
several maps about what what's going on
and um
who's who in new hampshire agricultural
listing the heads of all the
organizations those things take on a
tremendous amount of
time one of the things that i had hoped
to accomplish when i was commissioner
was getting a uh a virtual map out there
on the internet and thankfully actually
cooperative extension has worked
on doing that and so what i thought was
needed is now really up and
running through cooperative extension so
that you can go on there and find the
various farms throughout the state of
course it's only
to the degree that farms participate in
that but it's i think
very helpful resources
forward the division of weights and
measures
uh really has a lot more responsibility
than i think many of us under understand
and
the beer caucus members will be uh
interested to know that we're
responsible for making sure that those
cans and bottles
are properly filled
and that's that's true of everything
that is sold by weights of
measures uh that you know
we we are supposed to primarily do so
when there is a complaint make sure that
what is in the packaging is is correct
we license everyone who
is responsible for maintaining those
devices
all the service techs and they're about
um
we license approximately 20 000
commercial
devices they'll have to be licensed and
certified every year we don't do the
certification
we audit the work and the people doing
the certification
um those 20 000 devices are owned by 2
businesses and
we license 945 waymasters that operate
vehicle scales
that are used commercially and all of
that includes
your propane delivery oil delivery
anything that is that is delivered
um that way we are responsible for
for those so there's a lot of um
a lot of areas that we have to uh
to deal with uh and that's a very
important consumer protection
issue because you know if somebody's
scale
is not certified correctly then the
person could
we don't care so much if they're getting
more than they're paying for but we are
very concerned that they're getting
less than they're paying for and we want
to make sure that happens
that all of that extends into the area
of cordwood as well
and that's one of the most difficult
things we deal with because
people argue oh i delivered that wood is
not all there anymore so
it's hard for us to know um
but we do deal with that
we kept up with all our testing this
year thankfully we were able to
put both pesticides in
weights and measures when they were
testing or people who were
needed to be certified we were able to
use the auditorium at the brown building
over at the gallon office bar
and test 15 people at a time it meant we
were doing a lot more testing than we
normally did
but it wasn't something that we felt
would just say oh well your license
expired
you know you can continue to do this
without a license that would have been
less concern
than the people who wanted to be newly
certified we had to test them we had to
get that done
we were able to keep up with that
division of regulatory
services deals with organic
certification
good agricultural practice seal equality
program
the commercial animal feed and pet food
registration myrtle commercial
fertilizer commercial seed
horticulture and growing media usda
country of
origin labeling program
farm commodities such as maple products
apple cider honey
shell eggs local marketing best
management practices
ag nutrient management the grant program
and agricultural land preservation
monitoring program
so just to give you an idea here some of
the scale in that area
um obviously
it's a lot the number of
products in label review has increased
in the last 20 years and 68
just in the last 10 years
so we review those labels to make sure
that the ingredients
are things that the legislature has
determined are
legal to sell in the state of new
hampshire
theory we should also be going out there
and process it
testing all of the ingredients in this
sample in each one of those products
that is not happening right now because
of staffing shortage
we don't have enough people you can see
the just reviewing those labels is
incredible amount of time they're
between
the feed and fertilizer products we
receive um 17
000 products to be registered a year
we're above that now
and so that is a an awful lot
i'm going to just stop on statistics
there
well no i'm not going to i'm sorry on
organixx there's about
110 opera operations certified within
the state of new hampshire
40 participants in sea level quality
animal nutrition grants um
there were 18 landowners who applied
last year and primarily that's
from the newer pits and prevent runoff
so there are a lot of grants we don't
have a tremendous amount of money
there we try to really prioritize those
and make sure that water quality
is uh is of most
importance the country of oregon
origin labeling products there's about
23 stores that
participate in that the good
agricultural practices
program there are 12 10 to 12 farms
audited a year on that
900 companies have products registered
with us
12 feet there's over 17 000 products
fertilizer
or 8 000
61 seed companies and i will stop
there on that so pesticide control is
probably the division that we
cannot i'm almost done
a pesticide division
um probably the one area that we cannot
really fall down on have to keep up with
that because
obviously people are out there spraying
so we control
all the people who are licensed
do that and take that very seriously
because
you screw up there a lot of
environmental damage and a lot of you
have been damaged
so while i'd like to go more into that
obviously the chairman's told me
that i'm going to wrap it up the final
division is plan industry
which has four four full-time personnel
part-time apiary inspector one labor
intern in the summer
and deals with 700
plus licensed plant dealers 400
ap areas and really is
trying to deal a lot with the um
invasive species and that's both in the
insect world and the plant world
one of the things that we're trying to
do what we're trying to do before we
really get hit with a pandemic
is to partner with other agencies
and towns conservation commissions
really
hit hard with the invasive plants
anywhere down near hartford connecticut
it looks like a jungle
and i have sworn that when i leave this
job
we're not going to look like in hartford
connecticut we have to
manage those invasive plants
better than we are
commissioner thank you for the
presentation i would like to take some
questions but we're already
five minutes late for starting our next
hearing so i think what i will do is uh
if any
of the members of the committee have
questions uh certainly either forward to
me or directly to commissioner jasper's
office and uh we'll do our best to get
those answered for you
yeah all right
again thank you for coming in and i know
dr crawford is on and uh he'll be
answering some questions i'm sure as we
go through some of the hearings today
so thank you all right at this time
we're going to move on to
hearing for hb 627
fna
i want to recognize the prime sponsor
representative bixby
good morning thank you mr chairman and
for the record i'm representative peter
bixby i represent stratfor district 17
and i am the ranking member of this
committee
the hb 627
is a grant is a bill that is intended to
create a matching fund for the usda
value-added grant program
a value-added value-added producer grant
program
um and this is a resubmission of a bill
that we
got last year and because of the
pandemic we weren't able to study it
properly um
and it is a topic that i confess i have
not actually
studied as thoroughly as i um needed to
when i was
uh putting resubmitting the bill uh so
uh this year's bill is very similar to
last year's bill
the problem that the bill seeks to solve
is that new hampshire agricultural
producers
have had difficulty in competing for
competing effectively for usda
value-added producer
grants because the program requires a 50
match and uh that can be substantial
hurdle for a smaller beginning farmer
neighboring states have programs that
assist farmers in meeting the match
requirement
but we don't and farmers in in our
neighboring states have had much better
luck in
receiving these grants uh the intent of
this
the intent of this bill is to create a
grant program
to help new hampshire farmers compete
more successfully
for these grants in the course of
preparing the bill
i did some homework and the result of
that homework
is that i think this bill needs more
work before it can really go forward
but that the bill does really uh
but if we eventually if we get the bill
through it will fill a need that is
really there
uh so i think it might be uh
it might be appropriate for us to retain
this bill and
amend it so that it can really fulfill
its attend intent appropriately
i believe we have representative mick
williams with us online
and she's had some uh some experience in
applying to
this grant uh so i uh hope that she'll
be able to share some of her insights i
know she sent us
um an email with uh with some data in it
so with that um i'll close my testimony
and i'm happy to take any questions
[Music]
representative pearl we're not able to
hear you could you move closer to the
microphone
how about if i turn it on i bet that
would help
sorry about that
all right i don't see anything
we're still not able to hear you um is
the microphone on
yeah i'm ready okay i can try moving it
a little closer how's that
that's better much better yes all right
now thank you representative bixby uh
next we
will call uh representative mick
williams
excellent all right um hi everyone my
name is representative rebecca
mcwilliams
um my family owns and runs the lewis
farm here in concord
and we've been doing so since 2016.
we also have farm mentors bob and cheryl
perkins who run autumn view farm in
pittsfield
so the story i'm going to tell you is a
story of two farms
um so we we at the lewis farm
have been slowly working our way up from
doing a csa we're an all-vegetable farm
we've been working our way up from doing
a csa to hoping to do sales
at local grocery stores
our mentors bob and cheryl have been
doing sales at grocery stores for about
20 years so they're a little bit more
savvy than we are on this
specific topic um so
we have been very aware of the
value-added producer grant
both farms have been bob and cheryl
because a lot of their large squash
products that they grow
they actually need to send off farm to a
commercial kitchen for
processing namely as soon as you chop up
the squash
and you're ready to package it and sell
it to
a supermarket it has to be done in a
commercial kitchen
so for them it makes a lot of sense to
hopefully apply for and get one of these
grants
in order to put a commercial kitchen on
their farm property
so they can chop up their large volume
squash i mean we're talking about
thousands and thousands of pounds of
squash that they grow
rather than shipping it offsite for
packaging and then sending it out to the
supermarkets
um so they were really excited when they
saw in the market
bulletin um that there were two farms
awarded in 2020 um both got the 250 000
um producer grant
uh and both seem to be related um
obviously value-added means that you're
not just selling raw produce you're
doing something to it
uh so we we have kind of been this
supportive
relationship where my husband and i are
the younger farmers we're the ones going
online and doing the research
and bob and cheryl are the savvy farmers
who've been farming for 20 years and
know how to make things grow
and also how to get it to market so um i
i
did a whole bunch of research on the
value-added producer grant program
just to kind of get a sense of okay what
do we need to do to apply to get this
amazing 250 000
grant um so my research
turned up that really the way
program works is that usda insists that
you provide a fifty percent
match so obviously you would need to be
a fairly established business to come up
with another hundred twenty five
thousand dollars even if that's a bank
loan
in order to end up with 375 really
that's the goal
um to do the producer grant program
um so for bob and cheryl that's probably
going to be out of reach they don't
really have
the the means to get at another 125
000 but other states do have
programs that provide either
very low or no interest loans or
matching funds to help farms actually
achieve this usda grant
so i can see why this legislation as
proposed makes a lot of sense because it
helps the farm get over that 50 percent
match hurdle and certainly there are
other ways to structure it
but from my perspective i think that
that really is a hurdle if you want to
do something like a commercial kitchen
it's going to be a huge addition to your
existing facility
coming up with 50 may be a lot
just a little bit more background so my
family farm
we were looking at doing one of their uh
study
sort of planning grants which is the
lower cost
seventy five thousand dollars so we
would really need to come up with 37
500 for the match um that seemed like we
could probably do it
but um considering the current situation
with covid
and some changes in the market we are
hesitant
to to put that much capital on the line
and take the risk to do a commercial
small commercial kitchen at our own farm
we're thinking about doing canning
we do a lot of tomatoes so logically
next step for us would be tomato sauce
there's obviously more money in tomato
sauce and it keeps a lot longer
than trying to sell raw tomatoes through
the csa or to the public at our farm
stand
so this is just a tale of two farms that
are kind of looking at this vapg
from usda and saying wow that's really
great money we'd love to get at it
but um financially the obstacle to get
to that 50 percent match has just been
significant
and so i wanted to provide that
testimony so you could understand the
background is it is a significant hurdle
um
for farms who really aren't making a
whole ton of money doing what we're
doing but we know we could make more
it's just how do we bridge the gap so
i'm happy to take questions but i
thought i would at least
provide some context for this thank you
representative
are there any questions for
representative mick williams
i don't see any hands all right
thank you representative thank you
all right next up we will have robert
johnson from the new hampshire
farm bureau
we got you now go ahead great thank you
good good morning mr chairman the
members of the committee
for the record my name is rob johnson
and i'm representing the new hampshire
farm bureau as a federation's policy
director
and for those of you new to the
committee let me give you a few
sentences about what farm bureau is
we're a non-profit federation
established in 1916 of new hampshire's
10 county farm bureau organizations
we consist of nearly 2 thousand new
hampshire farm families
and over a thousand supporting members
statewide
we're a general farm organization where
members establish policy and direction
through a member-driven policy
development process
this piece of legislation as as
representative bixby
alluded to was initially introduced last
session
it was introduced by representative
david luno from hopkinton
and he did it at the request of one of
our members in and
took um kentucky creamery in hopkinton
and their concern was they had just put
in a
a dairy bottling facility milk bottling
facility
and they felt that they were
uh disadvantaged a bit in that
they were competing against producers
from
other states primarily vermont because
in the way
usda rural development is set up new
hampshire and vermont
uh basically share an office and and uh
again he felt without where vermont
producers they could access
state funding in new hampshire he could
not
uh so that was that was how this was
initiated uh uh on the at the onset i
want to say that
we are supportive of the concept but as
as
representative bixby said we we also
believe
it needs more work you need more
information
to give you a little background on the
the
the grants the the value-added grants
are
can be used by a
producer uh towards towards
adding value to a commodity and and to
give you some idea
it's where uh a a product is undergoing
a change in physical state like a fruit
to a jam
or it could be used for uh
marketing or segregation of a of a
product special characteristics uh such
as
organic grass-fed local that type of
thing
or it could be where a product is being
aggregated and marketed
as a locally produced food like a buy
local campaign or a state branded
uh branding campaign
or or also it is eligible producers are
if they're linking a farmer with a local
or a regional supply network such as a
farm to school
program so um generally the grants range
in the
in the range of 50 to 250 000
though they they can be less uh uh
than that and they are in a couple of
forms
they're in the form of a working capital
grant or in the form of a planning of
feasibility
and most common in order to receive that
working capital grant you
first have to have have gone through a
planning and
feasibility uh portion um
my understanding with the grants is that
they as
as we've said i think both speakers have
said they're matching
but on the producer end that that
that half uh half of that funding can be
in sweat equity
so for example if there's a uh say it's
a fifty thousand dollar grant
the producer is responsible for the uh
for the
uh uh twenty five thousand and and half
of that can be in
in in uh sweat equity uh meaning the
owner's time and after that type of
thing
a little background on again the
the uh the uh usage i guess of the grant
in new hampshire i found data for
five year period from 2014 through 2018.
and in new hampshire we had nine uh nine
recipients
of grants over that five year period in
vermont there were 17 recipients
and for further comparison purposes in
maine there were 24 and in massachusetts
10. 10. now you looking at the
difference in maine
and new hampshire and vermont again 9 to
17.
you got to remember that in new
hampshire according to usda stats
new hampshire we have just over 4 000
farms well
vermont is 6 800. so there's a little
difference there
and and then in some years like over the
2017-18 period in new hampshire we
received four
but in vermont they received two so i i
just think we need to take
take a closer look but where where
we in particular farm bureau that what
some of the issues that we see or
questions we have is
why tie this this money to just the usda
value added program
why couldn't there be a fund that that
any value added
uh producer for whatever purpose could
could access
and when when i know when when uh
this grant was initially uh thought of
it was really seen as just a small
porsche just uh
just uh like you might say uh uh yeah a
uh
a uh a micro grant talking in uh some
under ten thousand dollars we're not
looking at some as large as
usda another question is is the
department of agriculture the best place
for this
um should it be at another agency
and um again the the the the other
pieces i think we
there used to be more information found
on this what what are the issues and
and what are the obstacles and in in the
interest of time mr chair i'll leave it
at that and i'm always available for
questions
or to seek further information for the
committee
thank you thank you rob
are there any questions for rob before
we let him go
representative murray has a question uh
rob are you willing to take questions
certainly hi yes
uh yes thank you mr chair uh thank you
mr johnson for taking my question
does your organization have any idea of
how many
small new hampshire farms currently
would seek
uh grant matching funds like this have
you done a poll with your members or
anything
like that no we have not representative
murray
okay thank you any other questions for
uh
rob i don't see any
other hands raised all right thank you
rob appreciate it
thank you i also would like to testify
on on this bill hb627
see the answers all right
seeing done i'm going to close hp 627
and we will five minute recess
or about an eight minute recess and
we'll be back to take up
uh hb 532 and hb 438
starting at 10 am thank you
christine are you still on
yes i'm here we're having an issue with
um
okay hello yep
you'll have to mute your yeah okay
[Music]
i'm going to let representative kennedy
explain it so what we're having an issue
with is people
are going in trying to find an option to
testify
and they're not easily able to find a
number
um can you email me so i can send that
link forward
license uh sure um
they should it's in the calendar
calendar it is
they might need they just might need the
um the web i
mean the webinar id to make sure they
get on the right webinar
that's also in the calendar
okay thank you christina is there any
way we can have someone from it come
down and
take a look at our our sound system it's
really hard for us to hear
it's it's not clear at all very garbled
okay sure
[Music]
just make sure
um
yes this year
within the calendar year
december
um
foreign
and i didn't
our next hearing
which is uh we're going to concurrently
hear
house bills house bill 627
and house bill 532 they're both relevant
to the animal database so i'm going to
uh call on representative peter bixby
to introduce house bill 627
i believe it's 527 i'm sorry
um no actually it's 5 32. oh what
i'm sorry i got it 5 32. yeah
627 was the last one uh so
uh for the record i'm representative
peter bixby
stratford district 17 representing dover
and somersworth
and um i am also a member of the ranking
member of this committee
so uh the uh
the animal database bill is a request
from the department of agriculture
markets and food and the core issue
is how animal health certificates are
handled
and i'm going to be presenting uh some
background
and a little bit of history and a brief
uh
a brief introduction to what the bill is
going to be doing
commissioner jasper is going to be uh
presenting
more about the nuts and bolts of the
program and
state veterinarian stephen crawford is
uh
also going to be available to present
his perspective on some of these um some
of the some of the issues
so what i want to start out with
is what is a health certificate a health
certificate is
it issued by a veterinarian after
inspecting a dog cat or ferret and it
certifies
that to the vets best knowledge an
animal is uh
that is offered for transfer or sale is
healthy at the time of inspection
and that certificate is good for 14 days
one
common point of confusion is that
there's also something called a
certificate of veterinary inspection
that's a federal document that you need
to take animals across state lines for
things like dog shows
uh or or fares or that sort of thing or
if you're going to be selling across
state lines
those are sometimes referred to as
health certificates and they are
completely different from the health
certificates that are being dealt with
in this bill
so there are three purposes for
the health certificates uh that we're
dealing with here
one is to assure the purpose the
purchaser of the animal's health
it also a second purpose is to allow for
the return of the animal
if it is discovered to be health healthy
unhealthy within
uh a couple of weeks and
the third purpose is uh
that the health certificate serves as a
record of transfer
until 2017 health certificates were
required to be sent to the department
and when they got there they were stored
in printer paper boxes because there was
no proper filing system
no staff to create such a filing system
and no
staff to handle uh the
the certificates in an organized way
in 2017 there's a statutory change made
in the trailer budget bill that made uh
certificates
made submission of the certificates to
the department optional
and this was because the the department
didn't really have a mechanism to handle
them
uh in 2019 uh statutory changes made in
the trailer budget bill
changed um or removed the definition of
commercial kennel
uh which had been used uh to determine
which breeded
breeders needed to be vet needed a pet
vendor's license
and it allowed um that that um
commercial kennel definition also had an
exemption for
uh small breeders uh who would uh breed
up to
fifty puppies or ten litters uh the
the changes in the trailer bill changed
the
removed that commercial kennel
definition and then
it changed the pet definition so that
the threshold for requiring a pet vendor
license was
selling 25 or more dogs
uh and this created a need to be able to
track health certificates better
uh but we the submission of them is
still
optional which makes it very hard to
track them
uh in discussing this problem with uh
the commissioner and the state bets
it seemed that the most labor-efficient
approach would be to create a database
into which veterinarians directly enter
the health certificate information
it also seemed that would be beneficial
to deal with rabies
certificates in the same way in order to
provide the state bet with a better
overview of vaccination data
and to uh provide municipal clerks and
veterinarians an easier way to deal with
them
last year's bill hb 1627 was designed to
do this
it went through multiple revisions to
strengthen the security and workout
finances and was passed by both the
house and the senate
but was part of an omnibus bill that the
governor vetoed for unrelated reasons
hb 532 as introduced
is the version that the senate omnibus
bill contained last
last june because of changes in
circumstances it's become clear that
this bill that a bill that just focuses
on health certificates
is more appropriate at this time i've
drafted an amendment
that narrows the scope of the bill to
only animal health certificates
removes all fees from the bill
adds a sentence to the confidentiality
penalty section
clarifying that there is a uh if a
person is charged with a violation
that person could also face a physical a
civil suit
uh removes land language allowing the
commissioner to pay back the ipm and
scale funds from the animal database
fund
and adds a 250 000 appropriation in the
second year
of the biennium to cover maintenance
costs
so once amended what the bill is going
will do
is uh it will direct the department to
contract with the vendor
for the design creation deployment and
ongoing management of
the database such that the veterinarian
will will
be able to directly upload health
certificates and the department will be
able to manage the data
to determine whether transferees of
animals
meet the threshold requirement to be
considered pet vendors
uh it will put in place strict
confidentiality requirements which will
limit access of the database on
a need to know basis and put criminal
and civil penalties in place for
violation
it will define animal health certificate
as a record in the database
and make changes to current animal
health certificate statutes
that reflect this definition it will
clarify health certificate waivers for
animals that fail
the health inspection for a
non-contagious health problem
it will establish the funding it will
establish the funding
for the development and deployment of
the database from existing department
funds
and it will request an appropriation for
ongoing maintenance in the second year
of the biennium
i got a email from the state
veterinarian steve crawford
um shortly before this
uh hearing and uh
the um
he uh said he meant he mentioned that
there might be a potential issue with uh
the confidentiality section and um
the ability to enforce the
uh the statutes regarding um whether per
a person might be in violation and uh i
believe he's going to be testifying
um in in the near future and i just like
to
make sure that he um comments on that
and um he also mentioned that the term
health certificate might be
better you there might be a better term
for that and
i'd like him to cover also cover his
recommended language on that
i at this point i'd be happy to take any
questions
um my question is is would this database
be limited to this specific parameters
only
or is it a lot is it going to be
expanded at some point
i'm afraid i can't hear
okay her question was uh is the
specifically too limited to this point
or
is it intended to be expanded into the
future
um that is that's a question that the
commissioner can cover better than i can
thank you thank you another questions
for uh
representative bixby
all right seeing none thank you
representative thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee all right
next i'm going to call representative
contoir to
introduce uh house bill 438
you can actually well if they're having
a hard time hearing you maybe you want
to move closer to a microphone
why don't we do that
all right representative thank you thank
you mr chair
uh my name is representative contra i
represent belknap seven
and i am introducing hb 438 it's
relatively confidentially of the animal
records database
i have also brought forth an amendment
um
so what this bill does is it just
protect protects the confidentiality of
any animal records in the department of
agriculture
or any database that they may set up
but it will at this present if this
passed as is
any records there would be protected
from
the right to know my amendment adds in
after the word information contained in
the records of requests for information
from databases
and any other information that the
department might be authorized to manage
in the future
i wanted to make we wanted to make sure
that this covered anything
so that it wasn't just specific to
health certificates in case the database
gets expanded we want to make sure that
people's
information is confidential
privacy is extremely important to people
i mean i understand that we need to know
certain things but people's personal
information needs very private and
that's what this bill attempts to do
and i'm open for questions mr chair
all right thank you representative are
there any questions for
representative commtois
um i was just curious that if the
impetus for this bill was
sort of responding to the potential
imminency of having a statewide database
or is there another
reason that had to bring this bill there
is another reason uh representative
thank you for asking the question
um the reason i brought this bill is
currently there is
not necessarily what some would consider
a database but they do have
information where if you call the
department of agriculture you could get
information pre-readily
from them and right now
that information is not protected
so we just want um so that was the
reason for this bill
thank you thank you representative
are there any additional questions for
representative compton
thank you mr chair for taking my
question and thank you to rep combat for
taking my question as well
um can you define what you mean by
personal information is there a scope to
that or do you have a vision for what
that
entails actually
um actually under the right to know laws
the information should already be
protected but
personal data such as name you know
where you live
things of that nature things that would
affect your privacy if they're out there
i mean if people need to know how many
dogs
or how many males or how many spays
that's general information if they need
to
know how many uh health certificates
were issued in a county that's general
information but if they
narrowed it down to say a specific town
and there was only one reader in there
well that would be too specific and
would not protect your privacy
thank you
thank you representative representative
bixby did you have a question
yes thank you for taking my question uh
representative comptois uh would you be
willing to
uh work with me to uh roll this language
into
the um the hb 532 so that as an
amendment rather than having it as a
separate bill
thank you representative bixby i
appreciate that i think that i
would like to keep this as a stand-alone
bill i
i think that maybe amending your bill to
include this language
but i still would like to keep this as a
standalone
thank you for taking my question
thank you are there any further
questions for representative contoir
do you see any more hands
representative aaron i'm sorry
that's right that's right um
uh and i i guess i could
uh ask representative bixby as well
since we're kind of hearing hopefuls at
the same time
i'm kind of not clear about uh how
the records these health certificates
are being
processed or searched or managed
at the department of agriculture at this
time
i mean do they have any kind of
spreadsheet that they
when they receive these documents do
they just stick them in a box and put
them in a corner
or do they put that information
somewhere
on an electronic like you know in in
an electronic means did you know that um
just may i thank mr chair representative
thank you
i think that the commissioner of ag can
speak more to that
um but i also want to say that a health
certificate just for people that don't
understand
they are only good for 10 days after 10
days
they're useless a health certificate
only is good for 10 days
thank you representative bixby did you
have anything further you'd like to add
to that
um i think that the um
the commissioner can cover that uh more
effectively in terms of
how he's planning on structuring and
using the database
commissioner do you plan to to testify
later
i would like to but i think to the
specific question of how
they're managed now dr crawford is still
on the call
he would be able to answer that question
much better than i could all right dr
crawford would you like to
come up and answer that question now or
save that later for a testimony
happy to answer it now if you like me
all right please do thanks
um well this the question i heard was
what do we do with the stuff
the health certificates we get now um we
have people go through them because they
only come in hard copy we have people go
through them and we do enter them into
an access database that we keep here
just
because it's our obligation to track how
many animals a particular person is
transferred so that we know when they
hit that licensing threshold that's what
the
that's been our understanding what the
legislature expects us to do when
someone gets a licensing threshold they
require a license and that's the only
way that we have to track how many
there are so uh historically we did just
keep them in big boxes
um but now we actually take the
information when it comes in
or as quickly as we can after it comes
in and entered into an access database
that we use here in-house
thank you sure any further questions for
representative comta
all right thank you representative so
this is kind of a different situation
this year because we're hearing two
bills at once
and um i have members that have signed
up our participants that are signed up
to speak on both bills so
i'm going to work my way through the
list and it actually looks like we only
have one duplicate
uh one member that's signed up to speak
on both bills so i i think we'll be okay
just rolling through the list
all right next i will call on uh stacy
ober from
akc stacey are you able to unmute
i'm here can you hear me you can thanks
for coming
thank you for having me good morning my
name is stacey ober i am
the government relations contact in new
england for the american kennel club
and i'm extremely grateful for
the committees continued working
to amend this bill and get it right
in terms of narrowing the focus and
allowing the department of agriculture
to fulfill its responsibilities
in ensuring that only healthy animals
are transferred
and to also have the means to fulfill
its responsibilities under the changes
that were enacted in 2019
um i understand this is fluid in terms
of
changes being made to the document i did
submit written testimony so i won't
repeat that
i do want to acknowledge the importance
of ensuring the protection of
individuals private
information and that public records
laws typically do provide
exceptions for when individuals privacy
ought to be maintained i know that the
citizens of new hampshire
take personal privacy individual privacy
extremely seriously and just wanted to
note that even in 2018
on a ballot you voted to amend your
state constitution
to ensure individual privacy and
not intrusion by by government um
into personally identifiable information
so i just wanted to make that
acknowledgement and i appreciate you
continuing to work to ensure
that those protections are in place and
to make myself available to the
committee as you move through
making changes to the bill thank you
thank you stacey is there any questions
for stacey
do you see any hands raised
am i right okay next time we'll move on
to nancy holmes
nancy if you're out there could on the
on the call could you raise your hand so
we can find you
okay i don't see nancy so we'll we'll
skip on maybe we'll give her a chance
here before the end
commissioner jasper did you want to
speak again yes i would like to
just speak i can speak to both of them
i'm going to turn to
dr crawford perhaps to correct me if i
say anything that's that's wrong um
first certainly we don't have any
problem with the privacy
provision my recollection is that any
time
that we have requests
that would involve any of the
information in our database
whatever you want to call it's not
really a database but
relative to health certificates or
anything we do not release
personal information that's all that's
redacted
uh if somebody's wanted to call up and
say how many health certificates did
howard pearl
have issue we would not give that
information i think that
dr crawford can confirm that but i don't
mind
belts and suspenders but i think that
portion of it really
is belts and suspenders but i don't see
it as is harming any anything because
i want to make sure that whatever we do
protects the privacy of it
of individuals so
as far as i'm concerned that's fine the
the database itself
um and i think dr crawford said
yesterday we're dealing with something
like
80 000 health certificates a year
we cannot manage those the best we can
you know they don't always get
entered and we're not able to um really
collate them in a way that's it's
terribly um
helpful and that's why we need this
larger
more sophisticated database so that
we're not
manually entering the information which
is what we're doing now as time allows
and that's why he says when it gets when
we get to it
and the important thing right now is to
get this process rolling
i would encourage you not to get bogged
down
in the details because this is not going
to be a database
that would be going live anytime
soon i would be extremely happy if we
were able to go live before the end of
the next biennium
i'm somewhat skeptical that that would
even happen
it's a little bit of a different
situation but we had a
database for weights and measures which
unfortunately was developed by the
prisoners i don't know who thought it
was a good idea to have
state databases developed by people who
were incarcerated but they did
and that's what we're stuck with in
weights and measures before i became
commissioner
doit was awarded the contract
to create the new database and to enter
the information and
unfortunately you know that that is not
like what we're proposing
which is really starting fresh this was
going back and
making the two of them work together
that was supposed to go live
within the first year of me being
commissioner i'm now in my third year
and we're still not live with that
program
so i'm skeptical
that it would happen anytime real soon
which would allow us
to work out any any kinks or issues that
we have
i do frankly want to develop this
database
in a way that if the legislature should
authorize
putting other information in there and
frankly you've heard about the tb and
the bursellosis
those are things that would be very
helpful to have i'm not asking for
authorization for that
i want to make sure that we develop a
system that should the
legislature tell us we can do it that
we'll be able
to do because we've got to went to the
21st century
or you've got to go back to the 20th
century
in the early part of the 20th century
and give us a whole lot more people
to do what you're asking us to do we've
got this conflict here
of wanting us to do jobs but not giving
us the resources
to do it and if you don't want to give
us the resources to do it then take the
responsibilities away from us
these are not things we have asked to do
these are things that
we are required to do either by the
federal government
or by the legislature and we certainly
don't have the people to do everything
without this database
so i'm not terribly concerned about
what's what's in there right now in
terms of what's going to get entered if
you want to take rabies out
that's that's fine you want to you know
the one thing i'm concerned about is
having a
funding mechanism going forward to
maintain this because these systems
are expensive to maintain we propose the
fee
my understanding is there's hesitancy to
do that
well then that's got to be a general
fund appropriation
if you pass this bill and finance has
not
agreed to give us at least one year of
the second year of the biennium
as as an assurance that we'll be able to
do this
i got to tell you that i i can't in good
conscience
take a million dollars up to a million
dollars out of my existing
funds and put it into a program
that is just would be a million dollar
paperweight
dr crawford gave me that that language
i'm not taking credit but that's what it
would be because we have no ability to
do anything with it
so there's two parts to this we thought
it's reasonable to have a
a fee i don't care how you accomplish
that
but we have to have that that funding
and we will continue no doubt
to we you
us together we'll continue to tweak how
this database works
going forward into the future but we've
got to get
this train out of the station and it's
going to be a long haul
to get it to the point where it's going
to be useful
to anybody thank you commissioner i
actually have a question for you
this may be better suited for dr
crawford but uh if so you can
i can divert it to him when he speaks
what do you any do you have any sense
yet of how you're going to
implement the users putting data into
the database i know that i've
heard in theory that you're going to
have the veterinaries themselves
input these health certificates into the
system
would would that be done would they have
access directly to the system or would
they send you a file that would be
uploaded to the system later on so that
they
the only access to the system would be
from the department themselves
no they they would be able to enter it
from their own devices they would have
an access code but the only thing they
would ever be able to see
is what they personally entered into the
database
so they couldn't go on and say all right
i'm going to put in howard pearl's name
and see how many health certificates
he's got because i think he's using
other veterinarians and i want to find
out
you know if i'm doing no he would not be
able to do that
they would only be able to do that tom
clerks you know
would be able potentially to enter
information but they would only be able
to see the information for their
accounts
the only ones who would be able to see
the whole picture
would be authorized users at the
department of agriculture
so as a follow-up if the rabies is
removed from this bill then the town
clerks would actually have no
reason to access this database that that
is correct
okay if you limit it to that at this
point
we would be just talking about the
veterinarians unless i'm missing
something dr crawford
but um yeah if we do it just to the
health certificates
and there has on that and we're not
proposing this here but we
we need to i think there's so much
confusion about health certificates
at some point we need to change that
that name because people do use the
cdi's as referred to as health
certificates and they think it is
at some point we'll be proposing we
change the name probably to something
like
certificate for transfer so that people
are very clear that it's not
or anything else except transfer
unfortunately we didn't come up with
that idea until late in the process so i
don't want to complicate it further but
we do recognize there's a problem there
and it does need to be
to be addressed are you willing to take
some questions from other members we
have a couple hands up all right uh
representative aaron did you have a
question yes thank you
um mr chair i
and thank you so much for testifying uh
commissioner
my question is i had heard earlier that
the health certificates are only good
for 10 days
so i am kind of i don't understand
what why you would have this information
like on a long term basis
because if i meant because
the legislature has set the number
of animals transferred at 25 at this
point it was 50 before
so you get a health certificate
on on puppy a then puppy b and so on and
so forth
now at some point the animals are not
necessarily transferred within that
period of time
and the database would allow us to
easily see
all right there are two health
certificates on puppy a that only counts
as one health certificate
but when there have been 25
health certificates issued for
25 different animals that triggers
the pet vending licensure requirement
and that's why they have to get entered
because within that one year period
which the legislature has said as soon
as you
the health certificates trigger that
that number
follow yeah and so
how do you track that now you have an
excel file or some sort of
file that the health certificates are
input into
and then what happens they are manually
put in
the technicians try to make sure that
they're not issuing
putting it in twice for the same animal
that does
happen occasionally and when that
happens and we notify someone
that they've reached the limit
very often they'll come back and say no
you're miscalculating because puppy a
got issued
three l certificates we go back and
verify that it's a very very time
consuming
process for a period of time
the veterinarians were only sending us
health certificates
upon our request dr crawford can
correct me now i'm not sure if everybody
is sending them an
all now or just some are i don't know if
we're getting all 80
000 sent in to us that's an overwhelming
number
i tend to think we're not but i'd like
dr crawford to speak to that
dr crawford would you like to address
that sure if you'd like um
you know we are not getting all of those
in now that 8400
000 is the number of official house
crypts
that if everybody was getting them as
the lower fires that would be expected
just to maintain the cat and dog
population new hampshire
on average lifespan and
not a growing or decreasing population
of dogs and cats
no we don't get them all right now we
haven't we
request them from veterinarians who we
know a lot of them and some people just
send them in because they don't want to
keep
their files don't send those back we
review those
and um as the commissioner said
we do our best to assure that we're not
duplicating those when we enter them
and we enter them into our infant access
papers here as i said before
we're not getting all 80 000 um
at this point an electronic database
where
ideally we wouldn't have to touch those
documents that would be entered by
an off by a veterinarian um
ideally they would all be entered and
then it's much easier for us to manage
your hundred thousand documents in the
course of a year than it is
by hand um that's
the answer to that question i've got a
couple other comments but i'll wait on
those
gonna let you guys ask other questions
with the commissioner
all right thank you i'll bring you up
once we're done with the questions for
the commissioner
uh senator kennedy did you have a
question
yes um so basically this database
it's going to work something and
crawford
i come from a large animal background so
would it work like global vet like where
the client itself would log
in have all their animals in there be
able to print off the certificate if
needed
and then yeah so it's good you're not in
your head so it's going to be along the
same so
with people have been expressing concern
well if you include radius there are we
going to
eliminate the need for town clerks to
even have their job so now it's just
between the veterinary
and the state instead of the town being
in the loop on this one
um i don't know bitsby or whoever wants
to answer that probably
that's what um i'm happy to
mr chair commissioner but um
let me know if you'd like me to sure go
ahead represent uh go ahead
dr crawford not there yet thanks um
the the proposed amendment
would take the rabies pieces out of it
um health certificates generally do not
go to the town clerk and they wouldn't
involve them
this wouldn't be cutting the town clerk
out of a process that they're normally
involved in
the rabies process my understanding is
based on the amendment the rabies
process would stay as it currently is
rather than add it to this electronic
database
thank uh commissioner and i think
there's a little
fundamental misunderstanding of you know
the rabies certificate
would be interrupt would be
under our original proposal would be
entered by the
veterinarian however when a person
went to the town clerk to register their
dog
they would still have to have the hard
coffee
because the town clerk is not going to
have access
to who entered who
who entered the rabies certificate so
there's no change
on the town clerk's office but then the
licensure would be able to
to be entered that the dog had a rabies
certificate and was licensed in the town
so that when there is a problem
that information is more readily
available to
uh to law enforcement et cetera um
but it would be do nothing to eliminate
the town clerk's role in this because
theirs is about
licensure
okay thank you any uh any additional
questions for the commissioner uh
representative comtel
thank you mr chair i have actually two
things that i wanted to ask thank you
commissioner for taking my question
the first one is it says that you um
department of ag personnel would have
access and others would have access to
the database
when you say other like who else would
have
access to that database i'm not familiar
with that language and the last
time i looked at it i didn't recall that
because i thought it was
others authorized by the commissioner
perhaps and i think that was just sort
of generic
language but um i don't know that that's
necessary perhaps the sponsor could
speak to that that wasn't language would
request it but okay
thank you yeah call mr chair thank you
one other question
when we talk about 80 000 health
certificates
are we including the health certificates
that are issued by the humane societies
and the shelters
per year because they're not entered
into a database they're not required
only veterinarians can issue health
certificates so we're talking about
health certificates
that are issued by veterinarians i don't
know what you're referring to because
so dr crawford may be able to
uh to speak better to the issue than i
can but i'm not familiar with
with an exemption for
animals being transferred by shelters
not having health
periods because it's all all about
diseases really and making sure that
we're transferring
healthy animals dr crawford did you have
anything you could add to that
we're happy to um there is an exemption
that falls somewhere between
representative kumpo and
the commissioner animal shelters are
exempt
from writing these official health
certificates for locally surrendered
animals
so any animal they import into the state
has to come with that interstate
certificate of inspection that you heard
about
and has to get one of these official
health certificates before it is
made available to the public and we do
we do keep records of those when we get
them as well and we
we don't get all the health certificates
that are written at this point but
we do get some of the official health
certificates for those shelter animals
that have been imported and then
then transferred out but the so there
are some
some dogs or cats transferred from
shelters that do require an official
health certificate but not all of them
did you have a follow-up i did have a
vote thank you mr chair thank you dr
crawford
so i guess my question was when you say
there's 80 000 health certificates
per year roughly being issued in the
state does that include those that are
exempt
does that never include the exact ones
that are exempt from having to send them
to the department
no it wouldn't it would not that's a
fair point no it would not um
i'd have to go back and look at the math
and i i don't know whether i when i did
that
a couple years ago whether i um excluded
them or not but i would say
without knowing no it wouldn't include
those
stuff yet thank you dr crawford did you
have any further
uh comments that you wanted to put into
testimony
i do um if if it's all right thanks um
i think the commissioner hit the nail on
the head getting the process rolling and
sort of understanding the long-term
funding obligations of this system are
our primary interests um
in the i wanted to touch on
the records protection comment that i
had sent in the email this morning to
representative bixby when i looked
through the
the proposed amendment and it's um
i'm not sure why i hadn't noticed it
before and i apologize for not
so as written at least um
it would presumably prohibit law
enforcement from getting those records
or in the department from sharing them
without a court order
um when you look in the penalty
provision i
apologize for averting my eyes i'm
looking at my other computer screen
trying to pull up the language so i can
read it to you
the penalty section in rsa437
the first penalty is a pet vendor who
transfers
animals without having a license to do
so as required by this chapter shall be
guilty of a misdemeanor
it's a criminal penalty that the
legislature currently has in statute
um the department doesn't have the means
or the authority to enforce criminal
activity
or criminal penalties the second
provision is
administrative stuff and that's usually
what we use license um fines and other
stuff
so our approach
when we deal with these folks that are
approaching
approaching the obligation to get
licensed we usually send them a
heads-up letter hey you're getting close
to what the law says you have to we have
to get licensed
many most of them are amenable and work
with us
some are not and some even after they've
crossed that threshold they're resistant
to getting licensed
so it it is our practice to only
communicate in writing with these folks
and after we've sent them
one or two of these warning letters that
you have to get licensed
we will commonly carbon copy that to
either the local police or animal
control officer so they're aware
it's up to them whether or not they want
to pursue criminal activity
as proposed um
these record protections would prohibit
us from doing that as my understanding
and i'm unclear i guess how
or if the criminal penalty would still
be warranted at that point
yeah i did i apologize for only noticing
that
when i read um the amendment this
morning and not
not picking it up earlier on in the
process
thank you dr crawford i'm sure i i
apologize um
and i i just i read it too fast so there
is currently a record protection
provision in
another chapter of law that we have in
rsa436
that protects all uh animal records
animal health records
from public disclosure which
again seems reasonable and has worked um
but that that exemption in 436 colon 6-a
goes on to say disclosure to local state
and federal officials is not public
disclosure
and this exemption does not affect the
disclosure of information used in
reportable animal health investigations
under this chapter so
it protects them from the public but it
allows
disclosure as appropriate to other
government officials and when there's a
um
public health threat presumably so again
there's already some language in statute
and maybe that was
i was curious how the two of those would
work together as well apologies for
stumbling over myself there
all right thank you dr crawford was oh
representative molly did you have a
question
certainly yes sir um i just want to make
sure i understand the database
correctly and the need for the databases
if i understand this correctly
that the system when you were able to
just
uh have a requirement for the animals to
protect yourself
there's already
that's correct we've been talking about
databases that we need within the
department
anyhow and it was obvious that we needed
to
modernize and we're trying to to figure
out we
you know we're stuck on this weights and
measures one but they're we're going to
have to continue to do that
with all the divisions um this is one
certainly
um that rose to the top because of the
change
but the need was already there and there
are you know as
i said there are other needs i mean we
should be looking at putting in the tb
in the
personalises so that we can you know
even when the feds were doing it it was
still
a lot of work that had to be prepared to
get the information to them
we need to modernize i mean we can't
think that we can
maintain a growing population
with a static number of employees and
more and more requirements so
yes this this has made it a crisis for
us
we are in failure mode when it comes to
the pet vetting standards
and again the record will show that we
have said that
as soon as this was proposed that we
cannot
do what we've been asked to do we are
not doing what we've been asked to do
no surprise to anybody
that we all sort of anticipate in this
coming year
as a stop gap is it cheaper to have a
database
or hire on a on a
you know 10-year plan to at least get
over this
initial crisis thank you for the
question
no no frank frankly
um you know i'm not sure that when you
look at it that it's cheaper uh even in
in the short term certainly we could
potentially get there quicker but
more expensively i don't know where the
money would come but
we also don't have any place to house
people
we literally are out of space at the
department of agriculture
and by the way just because probably
most people don't know it
we pay rent to administrative services
we pay a lot of rent to administrative
services
so space isn't free um and then they add
you know administrative costs to
everything so
even in the short term it's not cheaper
thank you commissioner uh representative
murray did you have a question i see
your hand is up
i did i have two separate questions so
uh
i just to clarify with dr crawford
if i may um you were referring um in
your
last testimony going just rewinding a
moment
to the amendment for since we're looking
at both bills was that
438 that you were referencing the
question of how it would work with
what's already in statute
no it was um representative bixby's
amendment that's the only one
oh okay i'm so thank you
and then my second question was with
regard to this
federal uh database or the versaillosis
and the tv requirement
and do you have any further information
of whether you would be
adding this information to yourselves as
a department
to the federal database or are you
required to take over it and
contain that information within the
department
um so the that's a fully separate
program than the one we're talking about
here but if you
if you'll indulge me just the
brucellosis and
tuberculosis information that every
state has to enter into this federal
database
each state is obligated to get their own
information entered we've just been
fortunate enough for a long time to have
our local usda folks do it for us
um you heard the story as to as to why
that's not going to be able to happen
going forward and so we're trying it
trying to figure out
um we've already signed up for for
training on entry into that database
me and another one of our staff so we'll
have to take that over at some point
here in the near future once we get
trained and
are granted access to that database okay
thank you
sure all right seeing no further
questions i'm going to
move on to uh looks like nancy holmes is
with us now
nancy are you able to unmute and present
testimony
how's that we got just so we're
hearing both bills uh concurrently 532
and 438 and i have you listed as wanting
to
testify on both so i'm going to ask that
you just put your comments together and
present them on both bills if you're
able to do that um
i i think so um on the
one that just has the um information on
how everything is going to be kept safe
that's the the first one i'm sorry i
don't have the number in front of me
right now
on that one i listed myself as neutral
because as far as i'm concerned
reading that bill and reading
53532 the
there's absolutely no privacy possible
with the current 532 bill so that was
why i felt neutral on the listing i
think there's some
wording that could be changed in that
one and you know taking out the rabies
access information because it's not
needed
if you go with the amended version of
the bill
however i have seen the amended version
um of the of
where the hb 532 i've seen it
and i see some serious holes and
problems in it
um and in general one of the things i
wanted to talk to you about is you've
all gotten my written testimony i know
and i i hold by that but what i wanted
to make clear was
there are ways to transmit data between
businesses or
governments or people whatever without
anybody logging into the other person's
database
it's a decades-old technology it's used
all the time
to keep people out of each other's
systems and it's called electronic data
interchange or edi
it's easily looked up on the internet to
see how it works
i wouldn't say that we wanted to use the
strict protocols that are found in edi
systems
but what i would say is you can use the
concept which is
i have a file i want to send to you i
drop it off in a lock box
type location you pick it up you screen
it you determine that it's safe to add
to your database
and then yours your programs add it to
your database
there's no veterinarians logging into
the database
there's no um vendor pet vendors logging
into your database
there's just a transmission of data
the number of places in the bill that
show
that different people can log into the
database and do this and that and the
other thing
including others as the department
determines
to me that means there's absolutely no
security whatsoever
for that database if everybody's going
to have their fingers in it it's going
to make it far
easier to hack i'd rather see the
department only
have be able to touch that database and
then have the systems where
information is transmitted into it be
automated
think of it like you uh how you pick up
food from a restaurant now
you don't go in the restaurant they
don't come into your house to deliver it
you have a secure location maybe your
parking lot and they drop it off with
you
um so that was um i wanted to kind of
get go over the
concept of edi with you for that
and i could say in the um bill there was
still
established fees um there was um
um you know stills outlawing
outlining the bill itself outlining what
i think of is outmoded methods for
transmission of data between
like veterinarians and the department
which nobody should be logging into that
database except the department when
they're using it for reporting
or for maintenance among other things
this is going to really reduce
a lot of costs because if you have all
those people touching that database
they're all going to need tech support
you know notice how much fun we've been
having with zoom
okay i include myself in that
um everybody is going to have at least
probably two people in their business
that's going to be
wanting to access the database because
you can't just have one person do it
you're going to have to have a backup
person for when that person's out sick
all of those things you know combined
the fewer people you have that have
programs that are directly accessing the
database
the less tech support you have to deal
with
anytime you make a update or or
change things the more people who are
using programs specifically to access
the database
at um the department the more people
will have to go through upgrades and
again tech
support this is this isn't cheap stuff
um
so i i think you could really cut costs
on
on how much things will end up running
for the department in terms of getting
things done
and you may be able to easily cut the
number of personnel needed also
simply by ruling out all the extra
access to the database
and it's it's easily done i just i think
the bill right now
is just you know it's not taking into
account
all of the security holes that it's
creating
um i have i have a problem with that i
don't have a pr i have a
you know of course i'm with everybody
else and having a problem on the rabies
information being in the database i
don't want to see it in there
i want to be able to walk into my town
and get my rabies
have my rabies vaccination information
already there because my vet
sends it to the town that i live in
and you know just get my licenses
without waiting for somebody to
hopefully log on to
a database at the state level and
hopefully be able to get that
information quickly
and hopefully be able to then input it
into the town system
um it's just it's making it too
complicated and i think
that kind of complication again it
leaves um
holes in the system all right i'd be
happy to take any questions i think i've
covered pretty quickly everything i was
hoping to
um you know there's a bunch of nitpicky
things i saw on the amendment too but
that's the major stuff is that that
security hole is gigantic
and i say that from a background of
computer systems
thank you nancy are you willing to take
any questions absolutely
representative dutsy has her hand up uh
are you able to unmute
uh yes i just did can you hear me yeah
yes
okay um uh thank you chairman pearl for
uh for allowing my question
uh miss holmes the question that i had
are you suggesting
uh that the architecture of the database
uh
should be put into statute
i'm saying that i believe it is right
now being put into statute because of
the way it is talking about how people
will access it
who will access it and so on
um i think that that wording needs to be
out of there
so that um a level of secure system
could be created but the way it's in
here is it's got
it's got veterinarians signing in to
look at health certificates after
they've already submitted them
it's got pet vendors including shelters
signing in to look at stuff
on the database that's not needed
they do these places may need to
transmit data to the database
but they don't need to access it
afterwards
and the transmission can be done
securely instead of by somebody logging
in okay thank you thank you
any uh any other questions
do you see any other hands up all right
thank you nancy we appreciate you coming
in and testifying
thank you for having me all right next
we have
angela ferrari from the dogs group
angela are you able to unmute yes can
you hear me
yes we can okay wonderful uh thank you
chairman pearl and members of the house
ena committee for letting me speak to
you today
i am a representative of dog owners of
the granite state
and just for those of you who haven't
heard me speak at prior hearings
i've been working with this organization
that is an american kennel
club affiliated non-profit organization
founded back in 1991
and we're here to represent the
interests of all pet owners
we have a really robust community of
breed clubs
kennel clubs dog and cap readers
veterinarians mushers hunters
and livestock guardian dog owners just
for a little background
i have a few points to touch on i think
the conversation has been really great
today and a lot of good information has
been raised
well i do appreciate jas commissioner
jasper not wanting to get into the
details here
there are a lot of details in this bill
and
some of them are critical details as
we've been hearing today
i would be curious to understand how we
would stay involved moving forward if we
were to move forward without having
these detailed discussions
and ensuring that everything is covered
especially at a security
and confidentiality level you're
obviously noticing a lot of questions
and concerns
in that area our group has those as well
i'm going to bring up a few specific
points i did submit testimony to the
committee so you should all have this
as well and i'll likely follow up based
on some of what i've heard today
if there's still some additional things
to cover one of the items that was
discussed was the two different types of
health certificates that are out there
cvi being the one that is for interstate
travel or transfer as well as the
regular
in-state health certificates
the discussion was around you know how
to differentiate
an actual health certificate for
transfer versus those who are just
obtaining them for travel and other
purposes
and i don't think that utilizing cvi
certificates versus the general health
certificates is going to work
since cvi can be used for both
travel and transfer purposes so we do
have
both of those health certificates that
can be used for transfers
i did include in my testimony some ideas
about data being submitted
where maybe there's an indicator
that the veterinarian would identify
if this is a transfer health certificate
or if it was for travel or other
or a duplicate we do have duplicates
because of the
i think it's actually a 14 day window
that health certificates are good for
and if you don't sell your puppy for
example within that 14-day period you
would need to obtain another health
certificate
so it would be great to have
veterinarians be able to indicate that
this was in fact a duplicate
and that would help reduce some of that
research that's necessary
at the department of agriculture when
reviewing
the number of transfers anyone in
particular has had
so that's something that i would like to
have taken into consideration
as nancy holmes mentioned the bill does
outline rescue shelters and pet vendors
as accessing the database to submit data
i don't think that's necessary or
appropriate
mr crawford had mentioned that licensed
veterinarians in new hampshire were the
only ones who
should be issuing health certificates
therefore i think they would be the only
ones that would have a need to
get health certificate data into the
database
shelters or pet vendors for example
would not have the authority to
create or issue a health certificate
therefore
wouldn't need to get one into the system
this is also true for the waiver that
was mentioned in 437
colon 8 roman numeral 2-a
i think we need to remove the line that
mentions
licensed pet vendor or other person
authorized to submit the animal records
database
from being able to submit the waiver
so that's something that we need to take
a look at moving on in that same
section roman numeral five this is where
the animal shelter facility exemptions
come into play
we talked a little bit earlier about how
shelters are exempt
from submitting health certificates for
dogs or cats or ferrets who have been
obtained in new hampshire
i do think that we do need to add
information
that has that data tracked in the system
still because
those are still transfers and if we want
to ensure that those animals have been
transferred healthy
whether they have a official health
certificate or not
we should be considering how those are
being tracked
so that they are getting that level of
tracking as well
[Music]
in hb 249 this is another bill on animal
shelter facilities
a line is being added to
actually outline that shelters
are required to submit health
certificates
if an animal is obtained from outside of
new hampshire
and being transferred while they may be
doing that currently it is actually not
written into law it was dropped out at
some point
so we're trying to get that piece added
back in and i think it would be
appropriate for that to
be reflected in this bill as well so you
can see that on the second page of my
testimony
i've outlined both of those items to
make sure that they're considered
secondly in roman numeral six
last words in that paragraph
control the fact that health
certificates only need to be submitted
to the state
currently upon request and i think if we
remove the upon request
wording then that's going to make sure
that the law stipulates all health
certificates need to be submitted moving
forward
so we can ensure that the data is
accurate in the database
and that everyone is submitting those
health certificates and by everyone i
mean veterinarians
the last item that i wanted to bring up
today was
the fees we talked about how the
database was going to be
funded and how this database is
necessary due to the legislation that
was put in place
and putting
hard to enforce laws on the department
of agriculture
due to that i don't think that it is
appropriate to have the fees
put on the dog and cap readers of new
hampshire
we didn't ask for those numbers to be
reduced
we actually fought very hard against
that
and so to have any fees to help fund
this database
to help enforce the decreased threshold
and categorizing as a pet vendor and
requirement of being licensed and
already paying a 200
license fee to become a pet vendor
or for everybody else who doesn't get to
that threshold
i just think that it further burdens
that community and so we do need to look
to other ways to fund this database
[Applause]
and lastly i just want to support
nancy's
discussion regarding edi for the data
transmission
i think that is a great way to help
avoid some of the security concerns that
we have here
and getting the data needed where it
needs to go
and i would be happy to answer any
questions
thank you angela is there any questions
[Music]
do you see any hands on
all right
thank you for your testimony
all right is there anyone else that
that's on
would like to testify if so please read
my name is james gaffney i've had my
hand up for a bit i submitted
a request to testify
all right mr gaffney uh your name's
who do you represent and where are you
from myself i live in warner new
hampshire
okay thank you go ahead please address
the committee um
as reading through the the statute um
please forgive my brevity but this
statute
is incoherent
i would urge the committee to address
the problems with the statute
before trying to expand upon it i mean
there's a section in here that talks
about
duties of veterinarians and then as part
of that section it goes on to
to to discuss you know tagging of the
animal
right like so it's clear that it really
wasn't really well thought out before it
was passed
so now we're going to take a poorly
written statute and we're going to
expand upon it and then we're going to
take a cr we're going to create a
database and put it on the internet
that's accessible essentially
theoretically by
by everyone right because it has an
internet presence
just it's ripe to be hacked um
i'm i've i've now signed into a couple
of hearings
since you guys went to zoom and and this
is
my feeling on it the state can't handle
doing simple things like having zoom
meetings
for testimony do you really think we
we can handle personal information on a
dat
in a database that's accessible over the
internet
i don't i mean there's no discussion on
how that database would be secured
i would urge the state to come up with a
set of standards
and processes and procedures for
how the state would secure a database
not just for this
use but broadly in general there really
should be a standard for says
you know the box gets put on a
particular vlan that these are the
there there are firewall rules to
protect it there are acls to protect it
you know et cetera et cetera et cetera
there are no standards
and therefore this can't be secured
um there there's no
there's no expiration on the record so
the state is
apparently obligated to keep and
maintain these records
forever why would the state want to keep
these records
why would we want our records kept by
the state they should be deleted after a
year or two years or five years
right it's just a hot mess i mean as i
understand that the whole motivation
behind
this statue revolved or revolved around
thresholds for licensing is that a true
statement
are you asking the chair a question i'm
asking anyone i mean
my understanding right or wrong is that
this this
the rsa was passed into law
in order to to handle the threshold i.e
25 dogs or 50 dogs or whatever it may be
so that the state um can handle the
whole licensing aspect of this
well it seems like we're chasing our
tail over this right
instead of of creating this database and
this requirement
for vets to to submit all this
information
so that in theory the state could
tabulate
oh now we have a person that's this you
know cross a threshold
and we need to force their licensure
right instead of doing that
this information is already submitted to
the town clerk
and it's associated with a person and an
address right
we're required to for our dogs
and our cats to get to get rabies
vaccines every year
so why are we putting a burden on
veterinarians
and individuals to transmit this data
to the state so it can be collated or
correlated to
in order to theoretically come up with
who needs to be licensed
right and then the enforcement piece of
this instead
why aren't we asking the our town clerks
to transmit all of this information up
to the state
and then boom the state has the
information
it's simple it's elegant instead we're
creating this whole infrastructure
to accomplish nothing
i i really would urge the the
the committee to to itl this bill or
amend it so that it starts to fix some
of the issues with the statute
i mean you read through it as a normal
person it's incoherent
all right thank you mr gaffney is there
any questions are you willing to take
any questions from the
sure are there any questions for mr
gaffney
do you see any hands raised
thank you mr gaffney we appreciate your
testimony thank you
all right so we have another hand raised
oh
representative bolton did you have a
question
i'm sorry i can't hear
his question was is this bill flag to go
to a second committee
in and the answer is yes it is i'm not
clear yet i believe it's going to
finance
i don't know that it's going anywhere
else than that but i would have to check
with the speaker's office
my understanding is it's going to
finance next
yes
we certainly i i would agree that we
certainly should make sure we're putting
forth good legislation
it now it certainly will go through the
senate as well and where they'll assign
it i'm
obviously unaware of it but thank you
for the question
all right so we have um dennis goulet
with his hand up uh dennis did you want
to address the committee
yes can you folks hear me all right
um mr chair members of the committee
um thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak my name is dennis
goulet
i'm the commissioner for the department
of information technology for the
executive branch
of new hampshire um i'm going to speak
on to both of the bills i will start out
with the um
i'll start out with the security and
privacy topic which really i
think covers both and then i'll jump
into um
another set of comments um first and
foremost i want to address the assertion
in testimony that the state does not
have standards for security and privacy
of data
that is just simply incorrect and we and
our we have processes
that involve that are heavily involved
as it relates to the acquisition of
technology
and the standards for security and
privacy are directly related to the type
of information that we store so uh
so it's a personal information pii as
you would be storing
here under this circumstance and
personal health
information those are among the highest
category of information therefore
we have the highest requirements for our
vendor partners
or for ourselves if we're writing
software ourselves
that goes through the contracting
process which is reviewed both by the
department of information technology
in rfps requests for proposals and final
contracts when awarded ag's office is
involved in that as well and when we
have
legal questions which sometimes come up
with respect to how we would manage
a certain type of data they are always
involved in that process
in terms of approving the contract so
we do have a robust and mature process
for requiring technology that will in
fact um
assure the security and privacy of data
any system can be hacked though of
course so in any process can be hacked
so that is
you know we've seen that over and over
again in the united states
in the case of the question of edi
versus online access to
data you know one of the things about
edi that wasn't mentioned
is that it does put a technology burden
on the other end of the other
end of the transaction so for example
we do edi with lots of healthcare
entities in the state of new hampshire
and it's
it's pretty easy for them to do like
it's a hospital or something that's the
kind of thing they do all the time
if it's a you know if it's a smaller
entity it's much more problematic
and definitely having online resources
that are appropriately
managed and secured is
is important finally on in terms of the
security and privacy of data
one of the things we just were working
on and are
implementing is that new sets of
policies
as it relates to monitoring of systems
and particularly systems that are online
um so that so that we our security
our sock or our security operations
center can
watch and see what's going on in an
application for example
one of things we look at on some of our
health and human services systems um
and that's this is really enforced by
the center for medicaid medicare
medicaid
services cms is that we watch for
unauthorized access in real time so
things like that
so there there really is a lot of there
is
really is a lot of robust technology
being applied to these systems
we also have um we have
very sophisticated defense in depth
technologies to protect the systems we
have in our
in our data center and we also
work to secure and make sure that if the
systems are in the cloud
we are able to monitor them as well so
so i think that's that concludes my um
comments on
um security and privacy i will now move
to
resourcing um and this really is
i think more specific to 532
um you know i was disappointed to see
that there's no
expense side of the fiscal note there
while fiscal notes are generally for us
no fun to complete
we do we do like to complete them for
bills like this because
it helps us assure the success of the
program if it is
if it is enacted into law
and you heard uh commissioner jasper
speaking earlier about resourcing and
how long it takes to get anything done
in the department of agriculture from an
iet perspective i would
i would absolutely echo his comments
there
and um you know the department of
agriculture
has no full-time i.t staff to address
application things they have uh one
shared resource who supports 20
entities that's 20 2-0 so he you know he
figured he's getting about 1
20th of a person and that's what
agriculture is paying for
we had a similar situation until
recently with the office of professional
licensure and certification
and um so i've been here i may all be uh
six years as commissioner
and i in the first you know five years
we got very little done
there i mean we got some things done
here and there chipping away at it
but really we didn't get much done uh
oplc recently funded
um a couple of positions i t positions
in their organs in my organization but
dedicated to them
and in the past few months we've gotten
more done
in that organization from a
modernization
and an improving citizen service
perspective
um than we had the entire five years
before that
so um i will i will echo commissioner
jasper's
and in fact i'm concerned that the group
related to the success of this program
without dedicated i.t staffing both for
this program
and the other programs inside of
department of agriculture i don't
see us modernizing at any reasonable
pace
without that we have a staffing model
that fits well
into the size of the of the department
of agriculture that we've
successfully used at the office of
professional licensure and certification
i think that staffing model which is two
people would be perfect
for ag and i would encourage um
i would encourage us to think about that
particularly as it relates to this
program
and i would also encourage us to do a
detailed um
fiscal note on the expense side if
possible in the process
now that concludes my testimony and i'm
now available to take questions
us in the committee room we're having a
little bit of a hard time to understand
you it's kind of muffled
would it be possible for you to perhaps
put these highlights in an email and
send it to the committee
yes i absolutely can that would be much
appreciated
we do have a couple of hands up here for
questions uh
rep kaplan you have a question yes thank
you mr chair for taking my question
um commissioner goulet uh this is more
of a general question but
uh could you address the statement by
commissioner jasper that the
department of agriculture is having uh
databases designed by prisoners in the
state
and is this particular database also
being designed by prisoners in the
state's corrections system
thank you for the question sir um
that that system that commissioner
jasper is describing
is i think it's uh it's so very old
system
predates my uh my tenure but
uh no we don't we don't actually have
uh use the department of corrections to
do any of our i.t
work but i think that it had been done
many years in the past
thank you uh next we have representative
murray has her hand up
thank you mr chair for taking my
question and thank you commissioner
goulet
can you speak to some of the concerns
around
veterinarian submission or record
concerns with regard to perhaps even
when a veterinarian would submit a
record electronically
wouldn't there be some sort of
verification
um or a receipt of submission that would
give them
a confirmation that their data has been
transferred
um thank you um
if they were accessing the system as is
proposed then they would
you know again they get once a form was
entered or data was completed they get
acknowledgement that
that data was um was successfully saved
in the system
typically what we would do in an
electronic data interchange scenario
would be
um you know there would be also be an
acknowledgement
of receipt but it would be an offline
acknowledgement it would go back to them
so when we
when we have for example if a hospital
transfers information over to the health
and human services then
there needs to be an acknowledgment back
that that data was received
thank you very much
all right i um i don't any other
questions for uh mr goulet
are you seeing none thank you for your
testimony we appreciate you coming in
addressing the committee
thank you for the time all right i only
see one more hand up which is uh
nancy holmes wants a second bite at the
apple i guess go ahead nancy what
what have you got yes thank you mr
chairman um
i had um two things i think i whipped
through the edi stuff a little too
quickly
so that not everybody heard what i was
saying which was that
not that we would use the exact edi
protocol because i know exactly how much
work that takes on either end but that
we use the concept
of having the sender
drop the data off and the updating be
done on the side
of the person with the database without
the sender having to have
their hands in the database to the
directly
um it was just to increase security for
the transmission of the information
um the other thing was i totally forgot
to ask
was who's going to enforce that health
certificates are obtained
for transfer this bill allows not just
for puppies by vendors
this bill says anybody who is
transferring any dog
cat or ferret kitten or puppy or
whatever you call a ferret
kit all of those people will have to
obtain a health certificate
in order to transfer an animal that
means the general public
so far right now nobody does this
nobody i don't think i've ever seen an
adult animal offered
for transfer with a health certificate
other than by a responsible breeder
and so i mean who's going to enforce
that there are even going to be
any health certificates to be put into
the database
um as far as i know nobody does this
nancy i'm going to have to
wrap up you've had a shot here and i've
got people that want to speak so thank
you for your questions
right we have one more hand raised uh
gina scrafano and i apologize if i got
the name the last name wrong
uh yes hello can you hear me okay again
yes uh good morning chair and members of
the committee
yes my name is gina scrofano you
pronounced it perfectly thank you
i am calling today to speak in
opposition of hp
438 i do believe that the creation of
the animal records database is crucial
for the state of new hampshire
as representative from stratford shared
when introducing hb
532 health certificates do not only
indicate the current health and medical
history
of animals that are transferred in new
hampshire
which prevents animal suffering and the
spread of disease
including those that are zoonotic and
can be transferred from animals to
humans
but also to monitor the number of
animals transferred in new hampshire
which directly links to the licensing
and regulation
of pet vendors and the enforcement of
those laws and regulations
i would like to speak to one of the
major reasons
why the inefficient method of which
health certificates are currently stored
at the department of agriculture came to
light
which was due to the occurrence of a
slew of animal cruelty cases in new
hampshire over recent years
involving breeders and the cruelty of
hundreds of animals including
zoonotic diseases in order for law
enforcement and the state
to determine how many transfers of
animals took place in those cases
and to help determine whether or not
those breeders should also have been
licensed and regulated
it was nearly impossible to sort through
the tens of thousands of certificates
the department received per year
and track down the relevant certificates
to review them
so that briefly speaks to the gravity of
this issue
if we were to implement hb and
hb438 as written which prevents
accessibility of law enforcement
even by a subpoena it in major part
defeats the purpose of creating the
database in the first place
additionally pet vendors whether pet
stores breeders or rescues
they are making the decision to breed
and or sell or adopt
out these sentient beings that are
welcomed into the homes of residents and
become companion animals
any illnesses or ailments an animal may
have
not only could pose emotional and
financial hardship but also risk the
health and safety of family members
neighbors and communities residents
have the right to access information on
whether or not the pet vendor they are
considering purchasing
a valued companion from additionally
sometimes for thousands of dollars
are licensed and whether or not those
pet vendors have had
any violations to state law or have been
suspended
the public also has the right to know
where the animals were initially
transferred from
because when pet stores purchase animals
from breeders to sell to the public
that information on where those animals
were purchased from is included in the
health certificate
and the transfer records having access
to that information before a purchase
helps to prevent cruelty and the spread
of disease because it speaks to the
living conditions and the treatment of
those
animals the reason why the need to know
law which is cited in this bill
rsa 91-a was established
was for the transparency of government
actions for the public certainly that
includes which pet vendors the state
grants a license to
and whether or not they have any
violations of laws and regulations
similar to the u.s freedom of
information act which is used
on a daily basis just for these very
purposes
although i support the creation of the
animal database
we must ensure that the data is
accessible
in order for it to be an efficient tool
and for it to be meaningful
that's all that i'd like to share with
you today thank you very much
we do have one hand raised
representative murray did you have a
question
i do mr chair thank you thank you for
taking my question uh this question is
actually for the state veterinarian
um mr crawford is
is this um certificate like large
animals
for example have coggins in the event
that they are
yes we currently have uh mrs grafano
testifying so
oh i'm so sorry
did you have a question for her i did
not thank you
all right thank you any other questions
for ms grafano
thank you very much for testifying thank
you
all right listen we're running up
against the deadline here we've got
about one minute so representative
murray if you want to
make a quick question of uh
representative crawford i'll allow that
representative i'm elevating from state
veterinarian to now an elected official
or maybe that's not an elevation i don't
know
[Laughter]
all right we had representative murray
uh thank you mr chair and i apologize to
the previous um
for the error um mr crawford so my
question was with regard to large
animals
um like like a coggins would be issued
to an equine animal
um similarly with small animal transfer
isn't that some of the intent for the
health certificate within 14 days
to let folks know that those animals are
healthy for
transfer
um yeah the entire purpose of the
official health stuff kit
originally was to assure the health of
that animal before it's transferred
it is i think commissioner jasper
touched on this at the very beginning
that official health certificate is the
only way that we have to know how many
individual animals a particular entity
is transferred so that's why it's
being used in that fashion too but yes
the purpose is assuring animal health
thank you dr crawford you're welcome
do you see any further hands raised all
right i'd like to thank everybody for
testifying um
i'm gonna read off the blue sheet so for
uh
house bill 532 we had four people signed
and opposed
one in support and one neutral and for
house bill 438 we had seven
sign in in support and two opposed
all right so you know further hands i am
going to close uh the hearing on house
bill 32 and house bill 438
i'm going to turn the chairmanship over
to vice chair representative aaron
because
i am introducing the next bill
thank you champ thank you chairman
girl um but i'd like to open
the hearing for
house bill 226
which is the
relative to repeal of law on produce
safety
and to present this bill is the sponsor
representative howard pearl
thank you madam chair i come today
before the e a committee and i thank you
all for receiving my testimony to uh
introduce house bill 226.
so the department of agriculture came to
me and asked me to introduce this bill
originally because the
repeal date is coming up on the produce
safety laws and now every five years we
have them sunset so that we have to
review them and
basically make them effective again by
repealing the
the uh date so we i'm the original
intention of this bill was to
extend that date from 2021 to 2026.
there was a another
another situation that was brought to
light as we were approaching
and about a stop sale order provision
that is
uh in rsa 426 which is a separate
chapter of this law which is
rsa426a and that stop sale provision
it was a a stretch whether the the
commissioner and
his agents could apply that stop sale
language to
chapter 426 a if they found that someone
was in violation of the inspection
requirements
in 426a so i took in i drafted an
amendment which i'll
been presenting to the committee today
to add that stop sale language that we
modified slightly
from chapter 426 to make it appropriate
to
426a and give the commissioner that
authority
with that i'm actually going to wrap up
and let the commissioner speak a little
further if he would like to
to the to the provisions of this bill
thank you are there any questions i
would certainly be willing to take some
if there are
[Music]
does anybody have any questions for
representative pearl seeing none
uh i would invite uh commissioner jasper
to uh
please speak madam chairman
members of the committee and thank you
representative pearl for
putting the village amendment forward
to clarify the
fisma food safety modernization act
originally was with the department of
health and human
services that program was moved over to
the department of agriculture
a couple of years ago before it was
really implemented on the ground
it is a five-year funded program and
that
federal funding is up
this year and the intent was never to
put any responsibility
financially on the state to run the
program
so thus the hard stop date
and we are assuming that the program
will be
will be funded however if it is not
i would hope the legislature would pass
this but that the bill
would stay on the governor's desk until
such time
that we were assured that the feds were
going to fund it
and i i would ask the governor if it's
not funded by june 30 that he vetoed the
bill
in terms of the amendment there is some
some question
i don't think it's worth arguing about
in a quarter law whether the
commissioner has the
um the ability to stop sale of product
that has not
met the health safety standards within
fisma
and i think we all want to be sure that
only food that
meets those standards is offered for
sale to our citizens and
so to clarify that i would certainly
make every
effort under the current law to to argue
that i had the authorization
as i said i just don't think it's it's
worth having having a fight
there's an easy easy fix here so
with that i'll end my testimony and be
glad to take any questions
thank you commissioner do i see any
hands-raised
questions
no i do not so without
any other questions and comments for
this particular
proposed legislation i would close this
hearing
thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman vice chairman i don't
know i guess that gets confusing aaron
all right so uh we our next bill is
going to be heard at 1 pm
which will be house bill 272 so
we're going to uh recess until 1pm
and we will be back for house bill 272.
thank you mr chair
yes go ahead do we just
for however this works if we're recess
till one do we just stay on or do we log
back in
yes i guess yeah i think it's
recommended that you stay on and turn
off your camera and your
audio okay thank you
okay we are in recess until 1 pm
you